the largest study of brain trauma and
football players reveals the risk to
players of all ages
researchers at Boston University
examined the brains of 111 deceased NFL
players they found signs of the disease
CTE and 110 families of the former
players donated the brains after they
suspected injuries the study also found
evidence of CTE in college players and
younger athletes - dr. David agus is in
Los Angeles with the latest David boy
these these results are very disturbing
so a couple of things how big a deal is
this and how concerned should football
players be in the people that love them
be concerned about this these are big
questions and so certainly this is the
largest study done to look at brains of
football players 1928 was the first
description called punch-drunk
punch-drunk syndrome of boxers who were
peddling hit in the head and about a
decade ago who was described this CTE in
football players now what we're seeing
is that these repetitive head blows
caused neuro degeneration or the
accumulation of a protein called tau in
the brain and as it progresses as the
person ages it gets more severe more
symptoms happen so how concerned should
people be about this you know very
concerned you know we're seeing it in
high school football players and as you
get to college the numbers go up
dramatically and in the pros the numbers
went to 99% so this is a major issue and
if a child is going to play football
what we think at least the data point to
the earlier you start the more of a
chance of this happening then certainly
we need to pay attention here so we need
to change the rules or to figure out
ways to protect them the NFL says it
will quote continue to work with wide
range of experts to improve the health
of current and former NFL athletes and
that there are still many unanswered
questions about what leads to a long
term effects from the head from is that
enough from the NFL well a year ago the
NFL you know admitted that CTE can be
you know caused by repetitive head
trauma in football and so I like that
step for but I think a lot more needs to
be done we need to reassess the rules
the protective headgear we need to look
at ways that we can actually prevent
the progression from trauma to this CTE
and maybe there are medical medical
reduce inflammation in the brain we need
to really take an aggressive stance
because football is not going to go away
but we need to allow the football
players to live a long and normal life
you know is interesting because Hall of
Fame quarterback Ken Stabler Stabler's
brain was also examined for the study
the New York Times has that picture you
can see it actually on their website too
and it shows moderate CTE but what was
interesting to me about that is this
this affects quarterbacks too no
question about it you see in his picture
here that Brown in the bottom corner is
the accumulation of the protein of tau
if you put a normal brain there you
would only see that the really light
color not the dark brown and it's the
repetitive head trauma so it doesn't
need to be a concussion what we think is
just multiple repetitive head trauma
football players keep I mean
quarterbacks keep getting knocked down
during the Dre you see they're the
normal brain on the left and the severe
CTE on the right that protein or tau is
accumulated so in this study there was
even a punter that was shown to have CTE
Wow all right dr. David agus more on
this matter thank you so much